hi
everyone my name is minaj nandi and this
is my talk
games algorithms and social good about
the interplay between game theory
machine learning algorithms and the ai
for social good movement
first let's do a review of what game
theory is
certainly probably what is the most
famous game in game theory
the prisoner's dilemma so with the
prison dilemma
the story is as follows the police
arrest
two members of a criminal gang
for some crime and put them in solitary
confinement so the two prisoners cannot
interact with one another the two gay
marriages cannot interact with one
another
however the police don't have enough
evidence to prosecute them for a serious
crime and so they go to each prisoner
and offer them a plea bargain
if you rat out your
if you run out the other prisoner and
they stay silent
you will go free and they will get five
years in prison
if you both choose to stay silent you
both get one year in prison
if you stay silent and they rat you out
you get five years in prison
and finally if you both rat each other
out then you both get three years in
prison
and one common idea in game theory is
that we want to find this
nash equilibrium which is not the
optimal outcome
but it's sort of the outcome in which no
player wants to
change their action they don't want to
change their decision
if you fix everyone else's action so how
do we find the national equilibrium for
the prisoner's dilemma
well let's think about what happens from
player one or criminal one
if the other criminal chooses to stay
silent then you can either get a payoff
of
zero zero years in prison if you confess
and rat them out
or you get one year in prison if you
also choose to stay silent
and since you really only care about
yourself
you would want to confess you would want
to rap them out so that you get zero
years in prison rather than one year in
prison
if player 2 chooses to confess then what
you'll want to do is you'll want to
confess as well
if they write you out then you want to
rap them out in return and get three
years in prison versus staying silent
and
thus getting five years in prison so no
matter what
player two does player one will always
want to confess they'll always want to
rat out the other person
and because this game is symmetric the
same payoffs occur for player two as
they are for player one
the same thing is true for player two no
matter what player one does
player two will always want to confess
they will always want to ride out the
other person
as a result both players will want to
confess so the nash equilibrium
of this game is confess confess and the
prisoner's demo is very popular because
of this like
paradoxical outcome that two individuals
who are
acting optimally in their own
self-interest
lead to the sub-optimal outcome these
two prisoners are sort of acting
doing what's best for themselves and it
leads to this outcome of
three years in prison for the both of
them on the other hand if you look at
this game
you can see that there's a much better
outcome in which they both stay silent
they both
stay silent and they both only get one
year in prison and there's a lot of
variations on this game there's a lot of
research on how do you sort of shift the
equilibrium from being confessed
confessed to both staying silent
but that's not really what i focus on
for this talk and i want to talk about a
different game instead and that game is
the staghunt game
so the story of the stag hunt game is as
follows
there are two hunters and they have a
choice of
between hunting a hair like a small
rabbit or a stag
which is a large deer and the thing
about this is that
each hunter is skilled enough that they
can hunt the hair individually
but in order to take down the stag they
both need to have god
decided to go hunt the stag together and
you can see it here in the payoff matrix
that if both hunters go through the
stack they both get a payoff of five
on the other hand if they choose to go
get to hunt the hair they get a payoff
of two
if one hunter goes for the stag and the
other hunter goes for the hare then the
hunter who went for the stag gets a
payoff of zero
because they'll fail to hunt this to
hunt the stag by themselves and the
hunter who went who went for the hair
gets two because they got the hair
and if you work it out there's actually
two nash equilibriums for this game
there's stag stag and there's also hair
hair
and the reason i really like this diagon
game is because it shows the evolution
of
trust and value of communication there
are two natural equilibriums stag stag
and hair hair
but stag stag is clearly the better
equilibrium it's the one that leads to a
better outcome
and but in order to get this better
outcome the two hunters have to trust
each other
they need to communicate with each other
and so i think this is a
game that has a very interesting moral
in that the way to get the
mathematically optimal outcome
even if both players are self-interested
is by trusting and communicating
with each other and i love that idea
that like oh hey
in order to get the best possible
outcome we need to trust and communicate
with each other
that having these like that the solution
requires us to do these things that
are essentially good for all of us and
we need to have trust in communication
and i love that story more than the
prisoner's dilemmas moral which is just
like people doing what's in their best
interest leads to disastrous outcomes
like you know that's just
dystopian future but the sag hunt game
shows us a future where
people trusting and communicating to
each other opening their hearts to
another
that's how we win that's how we get the
best possible outcome
and that's sort of the theme i want to
go for this
presentation is that how can we sort of
achieve the mathematically optimal
outcome
by pursuing trust and communication and
justice and fairness
and so talking about trusting cooper
communication
i want to talk about this special
sub-branch of game theory called
cooperative game theory
whereas regular game theory focuses on
what the individuals doing what's best
for themselves
cooperative game theory focuses on how
do we build the optimal team of players
and rather than in cooperative games the
unit we focus on
is over a coalition it's a group of
players whereas in a normal form game we
focus on the individual player
themselves
in cooperative games we care about the
coalition we care about the group of
players
and the main idea behind cooperative
game theory is we want to
build a team of players to achieve some
common outcome we want to assemble a
team of
soccer players or football players that
are most likely to win
all the matches they come across we want
to build a team of pokemon
that are most likely to win the most
battles for example
and this idea of how we build strong
teams and the theory behind it
appears a lot in ensemble learning and
machine learning
with ensemble learning and machine
learning you're either boosting or
bagging a group of machine learning
classifiers
such as you build some like combined
machine learning classifier that's very
strong and robust and has higher
predictive accuracy than any of the
individual components to it
and the way it's done is by using this
idea this idea of boosting comes from
this idea of cooperative game theory
that you want to build a set of models
that as you build your like combination
of models your coalition of models
you're sort of covering the weakness
existing weaknesses so when you add
model two in existence to model one
model two covers the weaknesses of model
one
and more interestingly and more recently
we've seen this
ideas of cooperative game theory arise
in this field of machine learning model
interpretability and model
explainability
researchers have thought about how can
we use how can we view this idea of
feature attribution and model
explainability as a cooperative game
and the idea is that the features of the
model are seen as players of the game
and the model's output is the result of
the game so the features of the models
are trying to work together
in order to get the best output for the
model
so how does this work well it uses this
idea of shapley values
and the key idea behind shapley values
is so can we measure
how much each player contributes to the
team you hear a lot about this idea of
like an mvp the most valuable player
and the idea behind the mvp is that that
player contributes the most to that team
and how can we thus mathematically
formalize this idea of player
contribution
well the heuristic we're going to use is
that if you remove that player from the
team
and the outcome doesn't change that
player wasn't really useful at all
if the team would have won without that
player the player didn't really do
anything uh conversely if the team would
have lost
when the team loses with that player and
the team would have lost without
that player then the player still wasn't
useful in changing the outcome
and so how do you compute the shapley
value for a particular player
we serve iterate through all possible
combinations of the team
comparing the outcome when the player
was present
and subtracting the outcome when the
player is not present
if the uh the outcome does not change
that difference as you see
in this uh visualization here would then
be zero and so that marginal
contribution becomes zero
and with this you can sort of iterate
through all possible combinations you
can see like which combinations the
player did contribute something which
ones the players didn't contribute
something
and sum that all up and you say that's
the shapley value or the marginal
contribution of that player
so how does it apply to machine learning
explainability and machine learning
interpretability
well we can sort of do the same thing
with uh machine learning features you
can sort of take out
you can take a set of features remove
one and see how the model's performance
or prediction changes
when you remove that feature if the
model's prediction does not change
then that feature wasn't really
important it really didn't do anything
for that particular decision on the
other hand if you remove that feature
you set that feature to zero if it's a
numerical feature or you set it to like
the default category if it's
a categorical feature
then that feature wasn't really useful
if the mouse outcome did change on the
other hand then that feature
was useful that changing that feature
from the
its value to the null baseline value did
change the outcome then that feature has
some marginal contribution to this
output or that prediction and so how do
you do this in
actual implementation well this a python
library called shap
short for shapley values created by
scott lumberg
and that is very popular and it's like
probably the
current uh standard for model
explainability
and so one thing in this shop library is
this tree shop algorithm
it's sharply values for xg boost or any
sort of random force or gradient boosted
tree
and how tree shape works is that well
instead of brute forcing all
2n combination possible combinations of
the features
you can sort of take advantage of the
hierarchical nature of the decision tree
in order to test out different
combinations of features you can test
out age
education marital status for example and
then also test out age education marital
status occupation and work
class and see how the outcome changes
there and that allows you to infer
um age education marital status
occupation and age educational status
and work class you can sort of
approximate those intermediates quickly
so you don't have to brute force all
possible sub combinations of the
features
and so like i said shaft is probably the
standard for
model explainability at this point and
there have been a lot of like variations
or
frameworks built on top of shaft such as
like baseline shaft
or conditional sharply values
but in addition to feature importance
for feature attribution
there's also this idea of how can we
sort of create a value of data points
using sharply values and so there's this
one idea in algorithmic fairness of
how do we compensate individuals for
their data
the idea being that like google and
facebook they process all your data
and they make lots of money off it you
should be able to get some of those
uh set you should be able to be earning
some interest on that if
they're making money off your data you
should be rewarded for your data
there's a lot of like ethical and moral
qualms about that
that won't get into this point but it is
an idea that's being discussed whether
it's a good or bad ideas beyond the
scope of this talk
so let's talk about the framework for
this problem if we want to create a
valuation of data
the idea is that we have the training
points they the training
the we have the data points in the
training data set as players of the game
and given some learning algorithms so
given a random force or given
a neural network and some performance
metrics such as
accuracy on some holdout test data set
we want to
optimize the performance metric given
the data set
and the thing is here the idea is being
is that if you sort of take that
training data set and you remove a
particular point
and the performance metrics changes so
if you remove a particular data point
from the training data set
and suddenly the accuracy on the test
holdout data set
drops significantly well then that data
point was very very valuable
and where this might occur is in data
sets that don't have equal
representation of all
the underlying features so for example
we talk about like computer vision
problems
so there are a lot of issues where
computer vision systems such as face
recognition systems or face detection
systems
struggle at detecting black female faces
compared to white male faces
so adding another black female
face in your training data set may
improve the
performance of that model on the hold
out test data set
and conversely removing a black female
data point face from your training data
set may significantly drop
your model's performance on some test
hold out data set because that there's
less representation of black female
faces in your training data now compared
to white male faces where they're much
more plentiful
and the goal behind this equitable
evaluation of data framework proposed by
gorbani and zhao in this
2019 paper of data sharply is that we
want to compute the marginal
contribution of each data point to the
performance metric and so how do they do
this
they create this gradient sharply
algorithm so you start with some random
permutation of the training data
you optimize uh you update the model's
parameters using
stochastic gradient in a sense so you
optimize the model's parameters at like
reading one data point at a time and
then you
evaluate the new um you evaluate the
model at that stage
on the hold out test data set and you
see how
the change in performance occurred and
you attribute to that to the data point
so each step of this process you add
another data point to train the model
you see how the model's performance
changes and you associate that as the um
the contribution of the data point and
you sum this up uh you reiterate this
process until
you sort of achieve convergence and you
can get this good estimate of
the relative importance of each data
point in
achieving the changes in the performance
metric
and so i think this is a cool idea not
just focusing on shapley values for the
features but also how
shapley values can help us identify the
value of data points and this can help
you think about beyond just how you
compensate individuals
but help you think about your data
collection process process like
if certain data points of a certain type
for example if black female faces
have higher data sharply contributions
or
data sharply values then you may want to
get more black female faces for your
training data set it helps you address
like data set biases problems for
example
next i want to talk about this idea of
mechanism design
and now mechanism design is often called
reverse game theory
well why is that well the idea behind
game theory is we start with some
economic incentive structure so we start
with that payoff matrix
and then we try to find the optimal
behavior for each agent
so you start with economic structures
find optimal behavior
with mechanism design you do the reverse
you want to start with the desired
behavior for each asian
and such as we want our agents to be
truthful we want our agents to be honest
we want our agents act fairly
and then you try to find some incentive
structure that induces this behavior
well how does this work so let's
consider this very famous problem in
mechanism design called the cake
printing cutting problem
so you have two people alice and bob
because after all
all computer science problems involve
people named alice and bob
and they are given a cake and they must
decide how to split the cake between
themselves
and now we assume that each both alice
and bob prefer larger portions of the
cake they want to get as much cake as
possible
so how can we cut the cake to appease
them both
and formally we said we don't want we
want the cake allocation to be envy free
we don't want alice to be what bob's
slice of cake
more than she wants her own and
conversely we don't want bob to want
alice's slice of the cake more than he
wants his own
so what's one thing we can do so we want
our players to be happy with their slice
and we don't want them to be jealous of
each other
how can we achieve this well here's a
possible solution so here's
the mechanism for how we induce this
alice gets to cut the cake into two
proportions and then
bob gets to choose which proportion he
wants so assuming
alice is rational and i have an asterisk
here because i mean rational is defined
by rational choice theory
which means she's like mathematically
optimal and self-interested
she don't realize if she cuts the cake
unevenly so for example she cuts the
cake into like a 70 30
portion bob can always take
the larger portion of the cake so if she
cuts the cake 70 30
bob takes the 70 she's left at the 30
and thus alice is unhappy because she's
jealous of bob's portion
so in order to maximize our own portion
alex has to cut
alice has to cut the cake 50 50. that
way she gets 50
of the cake bob gets 50 cake she's happy
she's got the maximum amount
she can get and she won't be jealous of
bob's uh proportion because bob's
proportion is like equal to hers
and thus this framework results in an
optimal allocation that is both
proportional
it's fair and that they both get half
the cake and it's envy free and that
neither prefers the other slice of cake
strictly prefers so like they're not
jealous of each other
and this is a fun theoretical problem
but it actually has cool applications
through this real world
so there's this like non-profit uh
not-for-profit tool called splitting
which uses this idea of the cake prime
problem and it's created by
algorithmic game theory professors out
of carnegie mellon university
to use this idea of this cake cutting
problem and mechanism design to do
fair divisions of goods so if you're a
set of roommates trying to
decide how to like split rent evenly
among you based on like the different
rooms
in the apartment or household you can
use split it
if you're trying to divide up a set of
goods and say uh recipients of a well
you can use split it to divide up the
goods fairly such that everyone is happy
and no one is jealous of each other
and so i think this is a cool tool um
for
sewing the connection between like
theoretical computer science and
economics by applying it to a common
real world problem
and in addition to talking about how we
can apply mechanism to real
design to real-world problems i think
one of the biggest
contributions of mechanism design is
this idea of how do we design
exchange design markets for the exchange
economy so rather than
uh barter so rather than paying money
for goods
sort of like how do you barter with each
other i give you a you give me b
and most notably alvin roth won the 2012
nobel prize in economics for this work
specifically in the design of kidney
exchange markets so how the kidney
exchange markets work
well kidney exchange markets refer to
kidney donations you want to have a set
of donors and you have a set of
recipients
and we want to take kidneys from the
donors and match them to the proper
recipients
so how do you do this
you construct a bipartite graph graph
connecting the a donor d
to a recipient r if they have a blood
type compatibility so one thing about
kidney donations or any organization in
general
is that you have to take into
consideration blood types
with blood types there are those
universal donors blood o type negative
and those universal receivers blood type
a b positive
and the heuristic for how we make the
optimal number of matches is that we
want to be efficient with our matches as
much as possible we don't want to be
greedy
so there's no point in like matching a
universal donor on a universal receiver
a universal donor can give to anyone
and a universal receiver can take from
anyone
so we really don't want to waste our
donations on those because the universal
donor
could get to someone who has a much
bigger restriction and the universal
receiver can receive from anyone
and so what rob alvin ross's work shows
is as they proved a way to get the
maximum um
they produced an algorithm or mechanism
for producing the maximal number of
matchings in this kidney exchange
graph and this is actually what's
commonly used now across hospitals
in order to maximize the number of uh
kidney donations
thus resulting in saving millions of
peoples of lives or thousands to
millions of people's
lives each year so i think this is one
way to show like how you can use
mechanism design
to achieve socially good outcomes
and that leads to this idea of this
mechanism designed for social good
movement
this emerging area of research was found
like founded by radita bibi who is
pictured here
she was a graduate student at harvard
university at the time and i believe now
she is a professor at
uc berkeley or some uc school
and she's also the co-founder in the
black and ai movement and so how does
mechanism design for social good work
well it's a research initiative
to use ideas from computers theoretical
computer science and algorithm design
mathematical optimization and economics
in order to create
solutions and markets and mechanisms to
help
underserved and marginalized communities
and i think the key contribution of the
mechanism designed for social good
movement
is that many existing like data science
or machine social good or
ai for social good initiatives
often apply existing algorithms to the
problems with high societal impacts so
we're taking existing algorithms
and applying them to these types of
societal or humanitarian problems
the goal of this mechanism designed for
social good research is to create
new mathematical and computational
frameworks or algorithms
for optimizing resource allocation or
improving information access
to these marginalized communities and i
think this is important because i think
there's a lot of talk about like
how do we achieve fairness and reduce
bias and machine learning models which
really just treats the symptoms
and i think mechanism design is really
good at
so how do we address the underlying
causes yes you can devise a model
and make it more fair according to some
algorithmic fairness metric but you're
really just treating the symptoms which
is the model
uh performance but you're not changing
the underlying data with mechanisms
designed for social good by creating new
algorithms
a new mathematic computational
frameworks you are now addressing the
underlying issues you're changing the
underlying you're creating markets or
structures in order to change the
underlying data and i think that's
important
so let's talk about one example of like
mechanism design for social good and
this is a paper published by
radio bb on how do you allocate income
subsidies
to households that are risk of income
shocks
and so what this means if you have
households with low incomes they have
different successful susceptibility to
income shocks
so for example if you are barely
struggling to make rent and all of a
sudden you get hit with an unexpected
medical bill because you know there's a
giant global pandemic going on
or you get into a car accident and
you're hit with this like 500
maintenance bill or mechanic bill
then you're on them could be very close
to the verge of bankruptcy
and the goal with this research is we
want to allocate a set of income
subsidies to these households
such as that we reduce the risk that any
of these households experience financial
ruin
we reduce the risk that they experience
bankruptcy
and how this works is the authors use
this idea from ruined probabilities from
finance and like trading algorithmic
trading optimization to create this
framework to minimize the likelihood
that any household experiences financial
ruin
so how do they do this um like i said
here's like the mathematical formula
here essentially the idea is they model
the um the households like starting
income
they model the income flow so how much
like like mellow paychecks and other
income sources
but then they also model the probability
of income shocks
they model the frequency of income shock
so how
often does a household experience income
shocks and then also the size of those
income shocks
like you get hit with very large bills
very often unexpected bills very often
or you get hit with a
rare small bill on every blue moon once
in a blue moon
and so what's the problem formulation
with this so
each household i start with some initial
income reserve u of i at each time step
t
the household receives some net income
cease of i
however the households also randomly
experience income shocks they get hit
with medical bills they get hit with
like
um repair bills during each of these
time steps
and at each time r i of t
so basically the household's outcome at
time t
we would never want the uh the
household's total income to drop below
zero
and if you look at this and think about
it for a few seconds it has a lot of
connections to random walks you start
with some initial step
you go up you might go down if you
experience some income shock and the
idea is to always stay above that line
uh y equals zero you never want to go
into a negative
income value
so how do we solve this problem so
sincerely the problem is like how do we
allocate those income subsidies
such that the household's random walk
always stays above zero or
is reduced to likelihood that the
household's random walk never goes uh
never goes below zero well there's two
ways we can think about allocating these
income subsidies
we have some fixed budget b for income
allocating income subsidies
and we want to give a subsidy x of i to
each household
such that x of i the sum of x of i
equals b with two different goals
we have in mind when we allocate
subsidies the first goal or first
objective
is this min sum objective in this
objective we say that we can't save
all the households that some of them
will be
uh have to experience financial ruin but
we want to save as many households as we
can
so how do we do this we sort of give
each household a weight representing the
social cost of ruin
and in this formulation we sort of want
to minimize the expected like
a social cost of ruin by the value of
the household
times the probability of it experiencing
financial ruin if you're given some
income subsidy
and the solution to when you have this
objective function that you're trying to
solve for
is it can be approximated using the
knapsack algorithm
so how does it relate to an app style
algorithm it's like well you can think
about the
value of the household the the value of
the household is sort of the societal
weight like how valuable is it to save
the household is a side of weight
and the weight of the household is sort
of the income subsidy so
it's better to save multiple less
valuable households using smaller
subsidies
rather than just picking one big
household and using all your income
subsidies to save one household that has
a lot of societal weight
on the other hand we can have this min
max objective
and this objective we want to keep the
worst rune probability experienced by
any household as low as possible
so in this house and this objective or
this goal of min max
we want to save all the households
and how we do so we sort of view this as
this mid max problem we basically find
like what is the worst
um worst probability so what basically
what is the household
with the like the highest likelihood of
experience financial ruin
and minimize that keep that as low as
possible so even like the worst case
is still pretty good and so how do you
find a solution to this formulation this
min max from
what can be approximated using a
modified binary search
essentially you guessed some initial
solution solution p
if you find it infeasible address down
if you find it and if you find it is
feasible
adjust up keep doing that do a binary
search and you can eventually converge
to what is
the closest approximation to the optimal
solution to this min max problem
and so i really like this paper because
they show a way to connect theoretical
computer science
and mathematical optimization to a
problem that has a very high societal
impact
this is a framework of allocating income
subsidies
that can be very useful to government
agencies that work with like
low-income households and this can be
used to help these households
avoid financial destitution especially
during these times where people are
struggling to find work
they're very struggling to pay rent and
they're very they're struggling to
afford food and this could be a way to
help these households
have these income subsidies such that
they don't have to experience bankruptcy
or some disastrous outcome
and so that's really it from this this
talk i hope
uh here's the papers i referenced the
first paper is the
shapley the shaft paper itself a unified
approach to interpreting model
predictions by scott lemberg
next is the data shapley paper it talks
about how do you value data points on
the training data set
the kidney exchange paper by alvin roth
and finally the subsidy allocation
in the presence of income shocks by
radita bibi and other
professor researchers at cornell
university
in addition here's some further
resources for anyone interested in
learning more about
like game theory mechanism design and
the way you can apply these
game theory mathematical optimization
problems to socially good outcomes
so that's it for my talk and i really
hope you enjoyed that